perrier l'ile-de-france qui inquiète
médecins sans frontières selon un
rapport publié hier par luigi à plus
d'une personne sur deux en grande
précarité elles purent est infecté par
le coroner en région parisienne les
résultats issus d'une enquête inédite
le taux de positivité atteint près de
50% dans les centres d'hébergement et
monte jusqu'à plus de 90% dans les
foyers de travailleurs
sachez que ce taux aussi plutôt entre 5
et 10% au sein de la population
française et pour corinne tort à les
chefs de mission msf france
il faut proposer d'autres lieux
d'hébergement si cette personne sont
devenus pas ont été atteintes par la
copie de 19
tout simplement parce que c'est dieu
sont devenus des clusters c'est parce
que nous les avons mis tant d dans des
dispositifs qui était inappropriée des
gymnases en l'occurrence il est
impossible de gérer la distanciation de
gérer les gestes barrières les repas se
promener tous ensemble et puis pas
d'accompagnement de la part des
opérateurs qu'ils étaient eux-mêmes en
difficulté pendant ce confinement
on espère tout simplement que qu'il y
ait une écoute attentive du ministère de
la santé et que des décisions soient
prises en termes de soutien financier en
ressources humaines
et puis surtout qui des discussions avec
la dreale qui est le département qui
gère les lieux d'hébergement pour
trouver d'autres lieux d'hébergement que
ceux qui ont été proposées jusqu'à
maintenant